let's get after it Trump wandered into
NATO's quiet campsite in Brussels like a
big orange bear on a silent night
everybody was sleeping soundly having
the Obama dream where he tells you
everything's all right and then Trump
speaks and instantly the media and every
you bureaucrat goes from a sound snore
to hair on fire with predictions of
total destruction of Western
civilization by breakfast NATO was a
wreck and we were abandoning the Germans
to the Russians reminds me of a movie in
a world where many countries aren't
paying what they should many countries
are not paying what they should where
many countries OS a tremendous amount of
money for many years back one man had a
plan to blow the world away he is going
to fly into Brussels like a seagull he
is going to defecate all over everything
stock and fly away
when the world tried to pass the buck on
the good old US of A a man with a plan
brought a storm of logic I think that
these countries have to step it up not
over a 10-year period after stepping up
immediately nude man on unicorn
snowboarding through a ring of fire
while flexing presents Donald Trump
Angela Merkel and I and ziering as Steve
Trump NATO deprecating with everything
in Brussels like a seagull
Padgett hasn't anyone noticed a pattern
in these phony panics yet definitely not
the media who are like infants Trump
holds his fingers in front of his eyes
that says peekaboo and they all scream
mix every time until he feeds them some
strained Peas and then everything's okay
actually tremendous progress has been
made tremendous progress has been made
everyone's agreed to substantially up
their commitment they're going to up it
at levels that they've never thought of
before right in other words they never
thought of keeping their promises to pay
their fair share and that's the media's
real complaint here that we risked being
rude asking for what's owed to us in
public oh we're such oh please
it's like when the dinner bill comes
Germany is that dude who heads to the
John leaving you to pay and he expects
you will cuz you're an American
but he never dined with Trump
who won't let you go to the bathroom
people demand cash to your face
Germany's tab isn't paid on NATO which
was designed of course to curb Soviet
expansion yet the country is making
massive oil deals with the Russians
sorry I think Trump has a right to call
Germany out for skipping out to do lines
with pute Putin pipelines now Trump
watch everyone to up their defense
spending why would he do that maybe to
get them to meet the target they already
failed to me
could he be perhaps a stable of genius
I'm a very stable genius yes now as
Trump tutors us on NATO what is
England's response here's a rather
amusing way for protesters to show
they're not so keen on his visit here to
the UK here you have it the Donald Trump
inflatable baby they have come a long
way since Churchill flew a child's
response to adult actions kids playing
with a balloon now Trump is supposed to
meet with Putin which means that Monday
brian Stelter and Christiane Amanpour
will once again put on their chicken
suits and tell us it's the end of the
world and already they've forgotten the
Peter Strock hearing remember that I
don't recall writing that text if I
could give you a Purple Heart I would a
tree inquiry that is controlled by the
gentleman from our lumetri inquiry a
parliamentary inquiry is not an order
because you don't want it to be you at
least we have been we have indulged this
harassment you enjoyed 50 minutes of
badgering of the witness can you share
without a gentleman it's not your taking
up as you go along if you don't I'm will
suspend if it's so frustrating answer
the question the gentleman has already
answered that question so now the
gentleman from Maryland
Ashkan is recognized for five minutes I
can't stop it
is he an FBI agent or a bobble head
but that hearing it created a comparison
with Trump it's a group of useless hacks
versus the sole rebel dysfunction versus
dirty Harry
ballet slippers versus cleats a Prius
versus a monster-truck at the NATO
summit we got a guy Trump revealing a
hard truth with the hearing we got an
FBI love bird shielded by his white
night democrats so after all the
mainstream media freak outs maybe they
should stop screaming and listen to the
grown-up who might be on to something
I mean I never knew about that pipeline
and now I do again
Trump has dragged something out of
Europe's back room and put it on stage
and he didn't give to that he might have
violated some decorum that's his job
he's our jerk
the fact that he pissed off so many
people should endear him to us he's not
interested in being x man of the year
just a leader of Americans so he left
the summit with pockets full about forty
billion dollars if it had been Hillary
all she'd leave with is the silverware
true and meanwhile and while Obama Obama
might have been a lullaby Trump is a
wake up call a sex pistol in the land of
ABBA it's true it's true what the punk
movement did to music in the 70s Trump
is now doing to politics and if you miss
that now it's like you're still
listening to Emerson Lake and Palmer
which I
let's welcome tonight's guest ally
he's so Sharpie camper with a balloon
Washington Times opinion editor wearing
seersucker Fox News contributor charlie
it hurts
like falling from a tall building onto
hard cement he'll crack you up comedian
Joe Mackey she's mopey but never dopey
National Review reporter cat tube he
once tripped over the Great Wall of
China former WWE Superstar and my
massive sidekick Tyrus Charlie that's
Trump ruined the entire world order yes
thank God but no but you hit all of it
so well in that monologue I mean it's
it's amazing they got you know people
say that oh he doesn't like NATO he's
trying to undermine NATO he wants to
attack our allies but all the evidence
that people put forth for why he hates
NATO and why he wants and why wants to
undermine our allies is actually
evidence of the exact opposite
he's trying to get more money for NATO
rights trying to get support for now and
and the thing about the pipeline is a
perfect example where this is a guy who
is he's not afraid to talk about
anything and he really does educate
people about yeah and it is important I
I think it's vitally important to
understand that Germany is is is
spending money to basically finance this
great huge enemy that we're all worried
about exactly exactly and while the
whole point of NATO was to protect
ourselves against the people he's act
they're actually funding and then their
heads explode when Donald Trump calls
him out on I know it's crazy
Cyrus there are people who see Trump is
a jerk and it we get that I mean there's
people will see you as a jerk I mean
I don't know any of them yes Ben I never
get hold of my Texas make me get in
front of Congress that would I I kind of
feel for Jeremy a little bit because
they're kind of the world's bad guy yeah
they're always gonna be the guy in the
room like who's the worst person in the
room it's always Jeremy kind of gotta
wear that hat yeah so when he was like
well they're buying oil from Russia Joey
damn it like they never say like Germany
saved more puppies than any other nation
than him
Jeremy is doing backdoor dealings with
Russia again weird yeah exactly
once again Germany's the bad guy and I
think it hurt a lot of people's like
they were all like squirming and I think
like France and England wondering what
dirty had on them yeah what's he gonna
say next you know I like Donald
literally went in with a dirt like he
brought up everyone's sleeping who they
slept with six years apparently German
has been sleeping with Rush on the
down-low in there put it out there and
all he wants to do was talk yeah
Germany's laying pipe with Russia Joe
what are your thoughts on this are you
comforted by our stable genius president
I am and I when I read John Kerry's
criticism I thought it was almost like
Trump criticism mad libs where he filled
it out without knowing anything that
happened because he said that it was
humiliating
to to ask our NATO partners to pay their
fair share and he was glorifying our
enemy Russia when he was doing the exact
opposite if if he wants to look at what
embarrassed NATO was probably something
more along the lines of allowing Russia
to overtake Crimea yeah and doing
nothing yes
which was what John Kerry did exactly I
shouldn't I should said that
yeah I was just helping you out
okay what do you think about these
British protests you think they're
having any effect yeah I definitely
think that making someone into a giant
baby is like the best argument ever and
you're definitely going to win
no absolutely not it's absolutely
ridiculous and I don't understand why
anyone in America is mad about this at
all
any of the NATO stuff because Trump got
us paid he's getting us paid here yeah
and I don't understand because you know
they might not like him but if I had to
choose between someone liking me and
someone paying me I mean I would
probably choose them liking me cuz I'm
like desperate for self approval I
understand that the right choice would
be to choose the money so I'm glad that
that's what president Trump's done on
our behalf I believe I have paid people
to like me in some countries where it's
legal have such a hard time with
American sovereignty we settled this
once before
exactly it's such a stereotype though
it's the ugly American coming to the the
snooty elite Europeans and turning the
table over and then and then problem is
we're always kind of right my guess
we always Americans always do the right
thing after exhausting every other
possible option mm-hmm let's have good
food that's a good way of putting it
who said that Winston Churchill I know
who's he he he was the model for the
baby
oh I'm lying I don't care who you have
playing them they all have to wear a
pillow am i right Joe what's it I want
to last word from you I kind of think
that it's important to have a jerk for a
president because it's like having a an
a-hole lawyer in court like I mean if
America is a defendant in court you
don't want a nice guy you want somebody
who's like you know gonna go out there
like you don't want your lawyer to be
liked by anybody you don't even want to
like your lawyer maybe that's why so
many people keep saying it's so bad cuz
they actually like what he's doing but
they don't want the blame I do that
that's it yeah you want you you want
somebody else to take the blame we want
to be good cop and he's bad cop
exactly